- touché par le corps en un virus
notamment grâce à des restrictions
imposées plutôt que dans le reste de
l'europe la grèce 138 morts pour près de
2600 cas dans ce pays qui s'apprête à
sortir également de la mise sous cloche
les confinements progressif à partir du
4 mai avec les réouvertures des petits
commerçants sont que des salons de
coiffure et de beauté
le personnel médical dénonce le manque
de ressources humaines et d'équipements
dans la lutte contre le corona virus
certains ont manifesté hier à athènes
devant le ministère de la santé
c'est le but de l'action d'aujourd'hui
d'empêcher toute mise à pied d'un de nos
collègues nous exigeons plus de moyens
humains de disposer de moyens de
protection nécessaires de réellement
considérer les professionnels de la
santé et d'augmenter leur salaire
nous exigeons la mobilisation de toutes
les cliniques privées et que le
personnel indépendant soit inclus dans
un plan unique de l'état pour lutter
contre la pandémie